21 avril il y avait trente huit tranches
nucléaires en production tracteur trois
réacteurs qui étaient en arrêt fortuit
ça correspond à une situation qui peut
se produire prochainement normale trois
tranches en art et d'économie
combustible donc là c'est une stratégie
d'edf d'économiser le fonctionnement de
ces réacteurs pour pouvoir les faire
fonctionner plus longtemps et pouvoir
éventuellement commencer à aborder le
clic le clip de the edge of town et il y
avait treize tranche en arrêt pour
maintenance 13 tranches nucléaires
donc je ne décide pas à nos démons mais
voilà monsieur le sénateur médevielle le
docteur 1,13 tranches nucléaires qui
sont pas l'arrêt c'est normal même si
c'est un homme qui peut paraître
important à ce que la période de
printemps et est une période où la
consommation d'électricité commença pc
et où il est normal que d'étranges
semaine à l'arrêt propos a subi des
travaux de maintenance ou en état est
grave
avant d'affronter m le la droite qui
commencera éventuellement à l'automne à
partir du mois de novembre et 3 se
poursuivre jusqu'en jantes et de février
donc c'est cette disponibilité des
tranches de claire à partir de novembre
et jusqu'en février qui risque d'être
compromise par le fait que les réacteurs
qui devaient être mises à l'arrêt au
printemps ne peuvent pas l'être dans les
pentes était prévu et les arrêts sont
plus monde donc il ya un mais
techniquement alors voir dans le temps
où ces arènes qui devrait logiquement se
produire si en prenant la suite des
opérations industrielles on regarde
ailleurs de la disponibilité des
prestataires qui devrait plutôt arriver
à partir de l'été et à partir de
l'automne voire durant l'hiver ceux qui
peuvent poser un problème en terme d'
équilibre nos frais de demande de
l'électricité pour que le sujet c'est
celui ci c'est le sujet sur lequel nous
sommes en train de travailler avec edf
edf nous a présenté des directrices de
stratégie qui consiste soit à reporter
de quelques mois les arrêts qui était
prévu auquel cas c'est c'est tout à fait
envisageable d'imaginer des reports de
l'opération
de contrôles réglementaires avant une
épreuve hydraulique qui peut être révisé
en juin ou accepter qu'elle soit
réalisée en septembre prenant un certain
nombre de justificatifs donc le report
de l'arrêt ne pose pas de difficulté du
point de vue de la sûreté
un autre élément de stratégie présentée
par edf consisterait à d'une certaine
manière à sauter certains arrêts c'est à
dire ne pas faire des arrêts le simple
rechargement il s'agit simplement vue de
remplacer partie du combustible pour
pouvoir poursuivre le fonctionnement des
directeurs et avoir cette disponibilité
pendant pendant la période hivernale
c'était un élément d'une stratégie qui
est envisagée n'est pas particulièrement
des saveurs à lanterne sur take puisque
pendant les opérations de simples
rechargement il n'y a pas une opération
de maintenance nous on n'a pas beaucoup
ou pas de contrôles réglementaires à
effectuer c'est simplement comme un
automobiliste d'une certaine manière qui
passe à l'apprendre par essence et qui
fait le plein on peut très bien imaginer
que en supprimant ces arrêts de simples
chargement des réacteurs puisse être
disponible pour pouvoir passer le cap
des libéraux royoux ces éléments de
stratégie
les premiers éléments de stratégie ont
été présentés nous et discutons
nous avons également les conséquences en
matière de sûreté en matière de report a
éventuellement de dispositions
réglementaires et puis bien évidemment
nous continuons de voir quelles
conséquences tout ceci pourrait avoir si
l'effet domino dont je parlais tout à
l'heure où devait se prolonger jusque
jusqu'au début de l'hiver maman au début
du printemps de l'année prochaine
c'est clair c'est que jusqu'à jusqu'au
printemps nominal là il y aura un impact
est prêt semblablement y aurait un
impact soit la campagne 2009 2010 ça va
durer longtemps
cette opération de reports depuis cement
de reprise des travaux et donc il faut
que nous ayons la visibilité sur le long
terme
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
totalement ça ne s'ancre à me travailler
le point essentiel à mes yeux c'est que
par rapport à ceux à ce véritable défi
de faire face à la sécurité
d'alimentation électrique regard des
enjeux de sûreté c'est que l'edf
maintiennent les marges
parce que on ne peut pas exclure même si
en faisant toute la stratégie que je
viens des tickets indiquer si c'est trop
juste
c'est à dire si finalement la capacité
des réacteurs 1 2 et juste au dessus de
ce qui est nécessaire pour passer les
pieds divers à ce moment là on peut
avoir un problème en cas de deux de nos
problèmes fortuit sur un arbre sur un
réacteur
une défaillance portes noir acteurs
voire à un tueur un problème générique
qui pourrait concerner plusieurs raids
pour lequel en tant qu autorité de
sûreté nous sommes obligés de demander
l'arrêt ponctuel pendant une courte
période de ses réacteurs
auquel cas quand on n'a pas de marge que
n'ya pas pourrait ne pas y avoir de
marge nous aurons un véritable conflit
en terre peu sécurité d'alimentation
électrique et et de sûreté